pennant hello and welcome to this video
playing just kit I still have a bet
scoring and some I feel I did well in
the recent games but the statistics
don't support it he played the tell
Russian the recent games with this is a
tough opening to avoid not that I badly
want to avoid it but I just want some
variety yeah now to get a tunnel she
have to be kind of inventive no no he
seems to go for the Kings Indian defense
I think we had some Kings Indian games
earlier mmm so how does that work there
should be true probably i don't know
that line too well i mean i play it but
all of the time in blitz but i'm not
really a big expert and let's say five
is actually quite strange as i can go
before you okay so there should be three
four I don't know
probably I want to be a bit prophylactic
on the queenside f5 is difficult to play
anywhere do 2nite g5 I thought five
shouldn't work at all I g5 and if you
cannot go by five it's not so easy to
find a useful move here for black all
night each force actually move 192 all
night b5 just sent the Queen back to the
aid what is bishop is three years also
not better f5 it will be probably
leading to some weird complications that
I am Not sure that I need them let's do
it like this play completely for
prophylaxis
okay now f5 is difficult to play and
let's see I want I need to develop here
Bishop e3 shoot 45 night on b3 is not
well placed but I need the bishop out I
cannot keep it on c1 all the time yeah
provoking age 6 is a good idea a good
idea here question is 22 or 22 maybe and
then g4
okay MLG for the kind of move that the
ensuing position is very messy not
completely sure about it to be honest
yeah so taking twice is the normal way
to go maybe I can just take once for
Butchie one but I handoff I don't know
let's take twice
now it's a very it's very messy position
even though black has played a couple of
really question we move it's not clear
that I actually have anything because
the situation is that I'm that tough to
to play c5 I wonder fc5 is actually a
move to gain time mostly
taking the Roku
yeah still tough why it should be ok but
it's a very complicated okay why is he
going here like to get the Queen on the
G file that I don't see how cunha 3 is
looking wrong
nightmare come to h5 a very half the
plane and so you blundered 26 Bishop c5
but might not be losing kind of head of
unfair but it's not clear that it is
directly losing so what now queen bee
three g3 maybe also covering before time
morning night after night will come to
f4 this one further for the Queen trade
probably it snow queen trade I'd god
damn it
yeah okay I'm news totally losing
coordination now human check
yeah very bad result check
check
Jeff
can draw this maybe if I takes you
through the screen of one soul can alter
such a 23
check
check check check check check
check check check check late okay Wow
yeah okay that was lucky at the end very
lucky yeah I just I just don't score and
well enough against this I mean sorry
what black clay tia is just absolutely
absolutely bad and I did not punish it I
did not punish it this is always hurting
I mean you absolutely this this cannot
be right here just dancing around with
the night and then having to go back to
f6 so I mean how how good should whites
position be now I mean why it has to be
in excellent shape but I didn't play it
right okay this move probably is wrong
it felt wrong a little bit but I wanted
to develop okay maybe maybe something
else here okay the flicking this end
should be it should be good and maybe he
I'm doing it wrong yeah Queen d2 is also
possible this yeah the computer now
wants to play move that didn't cross my
mind just castling I'm also not clear
yeah maybe it is not so bad I mean it
looks frankly speaking quite ridiculous
to lose that time all that time with
black but one problem is that the night
on b3 is not helping at all on the King
side maybe I should start with G for yer
not play this just play this immediately
tried for oops trying to get the night
to g3 head is complicated is complicated
as weird as it looks more plugged it
here losing like
510 bo so they're in the meantime I have
played it before that means that my king
as in has an issue I mean this is
probably good for white but it's all
tough to play it's not not easy okay so
taking there and now very tough to play
ok c 5 went here again this time Jim all
looked quite quite normal very sharp
position and now he blundered this just
fully blunder the exchange but it is it
is still tricky it's so tricky my king
is in a bad position only one Queen a4
is a strong high given by the engine 287
and this is very strong getting the guy
wanted to activate the queen but I
didn't quite see that I can go to a 4
and a 7 and this is now very tough to
play in the Blitz game computer is
unimpressed it just gives 1.5 and says
wide wins but this is far far from easy
in an inner blitz game and I screwed it
up really quickly yeah your black of
course is completely winning Queen f2
was winning this also looks bad I can
just take the night oh that's a bad game
I can just take this bloody night
it's been a long day but still check
check no black is winning and here can
go 25 for draw which are also dressy
check check channel black is up a
million and now it's a draw actually
quite funny check check you're here
white is better who is better again and
now it is a sad isn't made now forced
mate checkmate stumblin reactor very
lucky very lucky and opening is really
strange black loses tons of time but
still has a somewhat playable position
it's really really strange and opening
ok well thanks for watching